le pido de forma concreta que nos
explique por qué se caracteriza este
nuevo texto y que lo diferencia del que
fue rechazado en plebiscito en
septiembre pasado
Muy buenas tardes gracias por la
invitación Bueno
en primer lugar creo que
existen diferencias entre el texto que
fue rechazado en el plebiscito de
septiembre del 22 respecto de este y sus
diferencias y sus diferencias están
radicadas fundamentalmente en el hecho
que este es un texto que trata de
recoger tanto
todos los principios que son enarbolados
por los distintos sectores políticos
Este es un texto que ha recibido una
aprobación de los veinticuatro miembros
de la comisión experta que va en que en
que existen representantes de todas las
fuerzas de la mayoría de las fuerzas
políticas de chile desde la izquierda
con el partido comunista hasta la la
derecha representada por el partido
republicano de tal modo que es un texto
más breve probablemente incluso pudiese
sentir pudiese leerse a veces contra
pero que en realidad permite a las
diversas fuerzas
con representación política que puedan
verse representadas en él y En
definitiva
dejar De cierto modo tranquilos a a los
diversos sectores y Gabriela le pediría
precisamente de forma concreta Cuáles
han sido los puntos donde ha sido más
difícil lograr acuerdos porque como
usted bien lo decía esta comisión de 24
miembros ha estado representada por
personas desde el partido comunista
hasta el partido republicano como usted
nos acaba de comentar
a ver lo más difícil para la comisión
experta fue tratar de congeniar
la idea del Estado social y democrático
de derecho en conjunto con la
preocupación de de los sectores más
conservadores del país de
poder que los sectores privados puedan
proveer de cierta maneras derecho
sociales como educación
como la salud entre otros
ese esa necesidad de congeniar que puede
sonar muy raro en Europa esto pero en
Chile es algo muy discutido sobre la la
idea de intervención del estado y al
mismo tiempo la participación de
privados en la provisión de los Derechos
sociales fue uno de los temas más
difíciles del mismo modo creo que no
pudimos lograr acuerdo en en temas
relativos por ejemplo
de interés por ejemplo para mi sector
como los establecer los derechos
sexuales y reproductivos y al mismo
tiempo también para a la derecha no fue
posible incorporar una cláusula de la
vida que está por nacer que muchas veces
en Chile fue utilizada
jurisprudencialmente un poco para
limitar o para muchas veces a callar el
debate político y jurídico relativos por
ejemplo la interrupción del embarazo y
hablando de estos difíciles equilibrios
que usted nos comentaba donde pues no se
han podido recoger las cláusulas que
quizás hubieran querido los distintos
partidos le preguntó si el hecho de que
la extrema derecha y la derecha tengan
la mayoría luego en el consejo
constitucional electo puede provocar que
el texto final esté muy parcializado y
sea muy conservador Bueno usted tiene
razón en eso pero nosotros tuvimos la
experiencia también al revés en que la
primera convención constitucional el
órgano encargado de redactar una
propuesta de texto constitucional fue
también eh
electo con una abrumadora mayoría de la
centro izquierda izquierda
en que no se produjo un buen diálogo
entre los diversos sectores políticos y
se produjo un texto que finalmente
terminó siendo rechazado Entonces el
riesgo más bien consiste en que no se
resguarden estos equilibrios y que
finalmente nuevamente un gran sector de
la población no se vea reflejado en este
texto constitucional y pueda nuevamente
ser rechazado una propuesta